I'm Ben Dominic I'm Ainsley Earhart I'm
Trey Gowdy and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday October 5th 2022 I'm Jessica
Rosenthal Ohio's been trending red for
years now but a democratic Congressman
thinks he's going to be the state's next
Senator as he distances himself from the
president on some critical issues his
opponent still calls him a rubber stamp
for the Biden Administration whether
you're a Democrat or Republican if it's
good for Ohio I'm going to be there to
support it I'm not I really don't care
about the Party politics I do think we
need to be American first and people are
sick of all these political fights we
speak with Ohio's Democratic Senate
candidate and Congressman Tim Ryan I'm
Dave Anthony it's been a week since
hurricane Ian hit Florida with Fury I
refer to it as Southwest Florida's
version of Hurricane Andrew it's so
devastating that it's going to change a
lot of things as we learn from it and
rebuild from it and I'm Tammy Bruce I've
got the final word on the Fox News
Rundown
[Music]
this week we spoke with Ohio Republican
Senate candidate J.D Vance about what
appears to be a tight Senate race in a
state that's been leaning red for the
last several election Cycles but when it
comes to that tightness Vance is
skeptical of the polling as data out of
Ohio has been wrong before Donald Trump
was supposed to lose Hillary Clinton
Donald Trump
by eight and a half points each time so
I'm I'm highly skeptical of the media
narrative that this race is super close
he says his opponent Democratic
Congressman Tim Ryan has been good at
distancing himself from his own record
and our job is to remind people that he
is not the moderate that he pretends to
be a CV commercials he is in fact a
rubber Stanford by the Pelosi the
pressure is on them both as the balance
of power in the Senate could flip
Republicans way with just one win though
of course that means keeping what they
have first and Ohio's current Senator
Rob Portman a republican is retiring a
democratic win here would obviously make
for a steeper climb for the GOP though
the Fox News Power Rankings and cook
political rate this seat as lean
Republican yeah I actually think uh
we're women I mean the beat on the
ground is very very positive Congressman
Tim Ryan is Ohio's Democratic nominee
for Senate we have a lot of Republican
support of people who are coming over
and helping us two-time Trump voters a
lot of veterans a lot of people that
just like my message on taking on China
bringing back manufacturing and I've got
a record here of bringing those you know
investment here from we've got chip
manufacturing we're building electric
vehicles cars trucks batteries solar
panels going all in on natural gas I've
been at the Forefront of all this uh
over my career and they recognize that
so Rob Portman's former Chief of Staff
is leading a big Republican sir Ryan's
initiative here in the state so it feels
great on the ground I don't think
polling is capturing all of that and I
think we're going to win the thing and
we're just going to make sure we you
know continue to touch voters around the
state in the next five weeks I know you
know who Mark Weaver is he advises on
Ohio politics and campaigns and he wrote
an op-ed saying that he's sort of
doubting the polling as well that for
example one poll relied on people with
college degrees as respondents at a 45
rate and that doesn't really reflect
Ohio's population when you hear from
somebody like that who's sort of casting
doubt does that throw you off at all or
sounds like it doesn't
well no it tells me that this is closed
or we're not winning is the fact that
Mitch McConnell has come in with 30
million dollars to try to rescue JD van
I mean the fact that you know president
Trump's here and the fact that Ron
DeSantis is here and that Ted Cruz is
coming and Marjorie Taylor green like
they're scared to death that they're
going to lose this race and you know if
you believe in markets working well this
is the political Market working uh and
the fact that Mitch McConnell got a
rescue JD Vance tells me that they're
very very nervous about that and I know
that that to me says everything you need
to know and I think they're putting more
money in which says that the first
tranche of money they put up didn't work
so they want to keep putting money in
here so that's all you really need to
know and I kind of you know I'm I kind
of like it I like the fact that you know
we're taking on the establishment we're
taking on all the big money and we're
still winning and that makes me happy
and that tells me that Ohioans really
want to vote for in Ohio and they don't
want to vote for somebody who's got to
rely
on you know even Donald Trump said from
the stage in Youngstown Ohio that JD
Vance is kissing his ass like people
don't want an ass kisser in Ohio they
want an ass kicker and and that's why
we're staying ahead in the polls
you've said you're running as an
American right not a member of a party I
think you've said that a few times but I
want to ask because for example as a
member of Congress 538 which follows all
the politics and all the polling and all
the data they put your voting record as
being 100 with President Biden I know
your opponent Mr Vance has said that
you're a rubber stamp for the president
what is your response to that how would
you shift or would you shift as a
senator on that voting record
well I will tell you that you know I
voted with Donald Trump on trade and
supported them on China voted with him
to renegotiate NAFTA voted with him on
his defense budget so I voted with Trump
on the things I thought were good for
Ohio and good for the country let's talk
about what I did before like a
bipartisan infrastructure bill that's
going to create 600 000 jobs in Ohio uh
the chips act that helped us land the
Intel project here that's going to be a
hundred billion dollars we're going to
manufacture Cutting Edge computer chips
in Ohio average wage 135 000 a year
since we passed the inflation reduction
act which not only puts about 300
billion down on deficit reduction uh it
also invests into natural gas which is a
huge industry here in Ohio building
solar panels building all the electric
cars trucks and batteries and the things
that I mentioned we've seen private
sector investment come into Ohio since
we passed that so if it's good for Ohio
I'll support it but you know what Joe
Biden wanted to reduce tariffs on the
Chinese solar panels I'm fighting them
on that you want to deal with the stuff
at the border with title 42 and get rid
of that I'm fighting him on that stuff
so if he's doing something that I don't
think is right I fight him on it not
everything comes up for a vote but my
record is pretty clear whether you're
democrat or republican if it's good for
Ohio I'm going to be there to support it
and I'm not you know I really don't care
about the Party politics I do think we
need to be Americans first and people
are sick of all these political fights
on that front you know President Biden
this year has mentioned that he would
support breaking the Senate filibuster
to get voting rights through and
abortion access through I don't know how
close that is to being on the table but
would you support setting that kind of
precedent breaking the filibuster for
certain issues
yeah I think that every legislative body
in the whole country every Town Council
city council County Commission whatever
it may be is 50 plus one majority should
Rule and I don't care if the Democrats
are in charge or the Republicans are in
charge but you shouldn't have to get 60
votes to pass something I worry that
countries like China can immediately
make decisions and get the government
moving in a Direction that's going to
benefit them and I just worry that we're
going to continue to have this level of
paralysis in the country and ability to
get things done unless we reform the
filibuster you should at least have to
stand down there and speak your piece or
stay on the floor I mean I'm I'm open to
how we do it but what about the notion
that the filibuster calms people down
cools things off and gives the Senate
more of that gravitas and more of that
time to consider things you you think
this whole thing should be done away
with
well I think you know the fact that they
have six-year terms should be enough to
have people have a level ahead about
things
um as opposed to running every other
year and having to raise money and all
of that stuff I think there's a lot of
ways to address that but look we need
people to be adults and have guts and
part of it is the guts to take on your
own party but say no like no we can't do
that yes I'm a Democrat but you're
trying to do something and I'm going to
say no like I did with President Biden
on the student loan issue I said no this
is not what we need to be doing right
now and so we need to elect politicians
with gut and and that will take care of
ninety percent of the problems that we
have in the country we can't have a
bunch of people who are just following
party leadership I ran against Nancy
Pelosi I got in place with Bernie
Sanders and I'll be just as much of a
pain in the rear end to Chuck Schumer as
I was to Nancy Pelosi but the reality of
it is if you have Leaders with guts the
country will move in the right direction
there's some polling data out of your
state that shows women are breaking for
you and this is of course of note
following the Supreme Court's overtime
of row but they're overturning made this
Estates issue and I wonder Lindsey
Graham proposals aside what could or
would a senator actually do on this
front like would you back some sort of
national Choice Law or something
well I think the reason women are coming
our way is one because of the Dom's
decision but also because Vance's
position are so extreme I mean he called
rape inconvenient and wants to force
somebody a woman underage even if she's
raped that bring the baby to term the
rapist baby State mandated pregnancy I
mean this is huge government overreach
this is big government in our doctor's
office in our bedroom and so you know I
being in the Senate would vote to go
back to Roe v Wade to codify 50 years of
law that you know had stability for the
country now we have nothing but chaos
the stories come out weekly in Ohio of
young girls who are raped who can't get
help in Ohio they have to go to Illinois
and if it was up to Lindsey Graham and
JD Vance they'd have to go to Toronto so
from the Senate I think you can be in a
position to codify Roe v Wade and let's
move on from the the chaos that JD Vance
wanted just a couple more for you from
your position in Congress you know this
past year we saw a record number of
people come into the U.S on top of just
this year an estimated half a million
gotaways fentanyl is flowing over the
Border as you know do you support the
Biden administration's handling of the
Border title 42 issues aside which you
mentioned and do you believe as some in
this Administration have said that the
border is secure
we we need to be much stronger On the
Border we need more border patrol we
need to use technology better at the
border I started the Border technology
caucus which is a Democrat and
Republican group to say how can we take
the technology we have in the country
and figure out how to use it to keep
this junk out of our country how do we
use it to keep and know who's in and out
of the country I mean there's eight
billion people in the world and most of
them want to live in the United States
but they all can't live here so we need
an orderly process of people of course
we should help refugees and people who
are you know threatened and losing their
lives and we shouldn't be ripping babies
from their parents ever in this country
but we do need to know who's in the
country and if they've been here they
should pay a fine they should pay back
taxes they should have to pass a
background check but you know we I don't
want our kids and grandkids fighting
about immigration law in 10 or 20 years
we've got to get this thing figured out
and that means working across the aisle
with a reasonable plan that can both
secure our border let us know was in the
country and keep this junk out of the
country who's killing so many people and
the reality of it is this stuff is
coming from China and it goes to Mexico
to get processed and so we need to
punish China and punish Mexico for doing
this
finally um I know you told our Fox News
digital team that you're you're not
inviting the president to campaign with
you you're standing on your own two feet
I think were your words
um you've been asked about campaigning
with the president before and I just
want to ask you know is it just honestly
like look Ohio's been leaning red it's
an independent-minded place you're in a
unique position here so it just wouldn't
make sense to highlight that kind of
bridge with the president with the kinds
of Voters you're trying to persuade
right now even if you voted with him
most often well when you invite somebody
in and they become your voice you're
giving up your voice and then you take
on all of their enemies as well and you
know I don't want to be in a position
where I have to take on anyone else's
enemies I am a very unique candidate I
have a very unique voice and you know I
don't want anybody else to beat my voice
no one can quite say how I feel like I
can and I want to stand on my own two
feet even if it's in front of Mitch
McConnell's 30 million dollars and Peter
kills 15 million dollars and all these
big politicians from DC are coming in to
help JD I don't care I'm gonna stand on
my own I don't need a rescue squad and
that's how I want it whether I win or I
Lose I'm going to do it on my own with
with my own voice and I'll be able to
live with the results either way
speaking of Peter Thiel he says that he
thinks Ohio's done that JD Vance is
going to win it and he's shifting over
to Blake Masters in Arizona what do you
think of that
15 million I think he's right Ohio is
done is going for Tim Ryan so he's right
Congressman Tim Ryan thank you so much
for joining us all right thank you
[Music]
this is Tammy Bruce with your Fox News
commentary coming up
President Biden will go to Florida today
to get an eye full of hurricane Ian's
destruction the whole community's
devastated it looks like a war zone and
I would say at least half the homes are
not going to be able to re be repaired
to live in them he is in Charlotte
County the damage the fierce winds and
violent storm surge did is even worse on
barrier islands like Fort Myers Beach
and Sanibel and Pine Island hit first
and hardest and cut off the bridges are
completely washed out the only way to
get there is by air helicopter or by
boat so we have been moving pallets upon
pallets of food and water he is with the
National Guard hundreds of thousands of
storm victims still have no power and
not just on the coast there was bad
flooding Inland up to the Orlando area
this man was rescued from flooding in
Arcadia 50 miles from Fort Myers
obviously we had to come through the
boat and it was pretty rough we thought
we're going to live the currents were
pretty bad but uh thankfully we're here
more than 100 people did not survive
hurricaneian with most of those deaths
in Florida I
Southwest Florida's version of Hurricane
Andrew it's so devastating that it's
going to change a lot of things as we
learn from it and rebuild from it Craig
Fugate is a former FEMA administrator
now Chief resiliency officer for one
concern what you're seeing is what water
does people look at that and I think
some people think that's wind damage
that's what the power of the storm
surgeon that water rushing in and the
pounding waves on structures just takes
everything out this path that isn't
built for those types of events you know
I think that the term storm surge it
doesn't do justice to what it is I mean
it's so devastating to watch the videos
of those streets that look just like a
roaring ocean when Ian came ashore it's
so violent and so powerful storm surge
seems like just a term that doesn't fit
what what happens I think we really need
to focus on is forecasting and providing
people both decision makers and the
Public's only the impacts of these
storms and really like this is the work
you know the weather service is already
doing with social scientists but really
get with the social scientists and get
with people and says when you heard
storm surge what did you think and what
would have you know having now gone
through this how should we have been
describing this so it would have matched
up before it happened would let the
impacts you saw certainly there are
people on Fort Myers Beach or Sanibel or
some of those places where Ian hit first
that if they knew what was going to
happen would not have stayed
I think there's a certain skepticism
right generally the media is just trying
to scare us it's not going to be that
bad we've been through these before
one of the challenges is and I think
this is something that we'll hopefully
do we've done it in past hurricanes is
go survey people in the area of impact
who went through the storm and asked him
what did they do that they evacuated or
why did you evacuate what information
did you use to do that if you didn't
evacuate you know how do you get your
information how do you make that
decision and this isn't about being
critical of your decision it's about
asking them how did they get to that
decision and if information was
presented differently would it had
changed that decision and if it was
presented differently how do you convey
that in a way that somebody who hasn't
ever been through this understands when
we're saying something like storm surge
that may be a little bit too sanitized I
mean I was telling people and I think
you know we talk about the leading cause
of death in hurricanes is water you know
we never say the leading cause of death
in hurricanes is drowning that's a
different image to people if they
understand that storm surge the deaths
are likely to be to Drowning when we
watch stories of major floods like we
see Rushing Water we see places like
Kentucky where streets become Rivers we
see homes that are flooded but in this
case you have the ocean coming in some
people drown in their own homes because
the ocean came in and filled the house
up and they died inside
that is something that most people I
don't know if they visualize that
possibility
now if you go back to superstorm Sandy
the majority of the people who lost our
lives during that storm also drowned
we've had situations in Florida where it
wasn't a hurricane it was a low pressure
system coming off to golf and up in
communities that are near where I live
in Dixie and Taylor County the water
came in so fast that people drowned in
their homes and I think that's the thing
people don't get the speed this water
comes in I've heard several people say
you know one minute I'm on dry land the
next couple of minutes I'm in the Gulf
of Mexico with waves crashing through my
windows and I'm going upstairs and the
water is following me that is so
frightening to think about
now of course there are a lot of people
who are in the boat of now what they
don't have a home anymore or it's so
badly damaged they can't live there
anymore
it's a daunting thing to deal with the
first step I has to be insurance for
most of people have it I you can't get a
mortgage without it but
not everybody has flood insurance right
uh they estimate roughly 20 percent of
the areas that had seen impact had flood
insurance we know the further Inland you
go and as you move away from the storm
surge and you're now dealing with the
Inland flooding that the rate of flood
insurance drops but you're right you
start with your insurance and you file
your claims uh if you did have flood
insurance FEMA has accelerated a program
and they are doing partial payments a
big piece of that that I think people
need right now is housing assistance
where FEMA will provide vouchers for
hotels and motels or rental properties
understanding there's not a lot of that
available in this area with the
devastation so people are going to have
to go out of that area but it gives them
a place to go to while they start that
recovery process people can get loans
too right the small business
administration makes Longs available and
because it's SBA people think I'm a
homeowner what's that going to do for me
well if you lost fences or outbuilding
the stuff that your insurance doesn't
cover and you need to make repairs the
small business administration makes laws
to both businesses and homeowners for
the uninsured losses in the disaster
area and then if you don't have
insurance you're economically just not
able to take out a loan that's where the
FEMA assistance and their individual
assistance program comes in and it will
provide some funding to people who are
who have their homes damaged but also
renters and if we didn't have you know
if we see people who didn't have flood
insurance had major damage the amount of
money that FEMA provides is not going to
make them whole but it starts to process
and this is where you're already hearing
the Congressional Delegation both of the
state senators talking about additional
assistance so things like the HUD
Community block development grant
program for disasters will need funds
there after hurricane Ian hit Florida it
moved into Georgia then out to sea and
then on Friday another landfall into
South Carolina and North Carolina where
four people were killed that same day
vice president Harris considered some
controversy into the federal response
telling a Democratic National Committee
event low-income communities and
communities of color are the most
impacted and so we have to address this
in a way that is about giving resources
based on Equity understanding that we we
fight for equality but we also need to
fight for Equity understanding not
everyone starts out at the same place
well that was widely criticized by
Republicans Congressman Byron Donalds
tells Fox listen I just I couldn't
disagree more with the vice president
now is not the time to be talking about
who gets what based upon where you
started it's about helping people what
does Craig Fugate think if you think
about FEMA's programs if you got areas
that are better insured that's not where
FEMA needs to be now the search and
rescue and all that is going to focus on
where those impacts are but in this
recovery process you know what I found
is you need to go where the greatest
need is that's not always where the
cameras are that may not always be the
parts of the community that everybody
sees but the needs are greater there uh
FEMA's programs are really geared to
people that don't have insurance or
didn't have enough insurance that are
going to be struggling to recover now I
want to ask about the insurance because
suddenly insurance companies have
this huge amount of property to deal
with and an unbelievable number of
people and customers in need
you also have to weigh that against you
are dealing with your property you have
to get things out of your property
things are damaged or destroyed you have
to throw them away you're probably not
going to see anyone from the insurance
company before you have a chance to do
that what do you do how do you get rid
of things that you know are destroyed
before you even talk to somebody with
the insurance company well hopefully you
got a phone even if you don't have cell
service if your phone's got a camera
pictures of everything the way it was
and start cleaning up and FEMA's clear
on this in their guidance on flood
insurance you don't have to wait for the
adjuster to show up to start making
repairs and mucking out the home just
take pictures of it document it and go
to work unfortunately we know not
everybody's a good person we've had some
arrests for looting but at this time
it'll all these disasters people always
show up ready to scam people out of
their money their insurance money their
FEMA money and all that what should
people know when they're trying
desperately to get work done in their
home first thing is FEMA never charges
for inspections or charges for the
application anybody telling you you got
to pay them to get FEMA money they're
scamming you second thing anybody that
comes in is offering to do work first
thing you need to ask for where's your
Contractor License this is to protect
you because if you have unlicensed
people on your property who get hurt you
may be now liable not only for the
damages you had but for their workman's
comp claim because they didn't have
workman's comp on those workers
also they may not be doing work to code
you have programs like the Blue Roof
operation that the Army Corps of
Engineers is putting out there again if
you register and qualify for that blue
roof that's done for you at no cost it's
paid for by the federal taxpayers so
when people are coming in and asking for
money up front be very very careful none
of the federal programs require you to
pay for those services and make sure the
person that is prepared to do the work
is a licensed contractor that they're a
licensed in that area
and again I I think there are people
that take advantage of that or we've
seen the horror stories where people
gave them a check for a roof repair and
they never showed back up and lastly
these people
who are dealing with all this damage
is a mental toll for every one of those
victims how is that handled down there
well there's a lot of services that will
come in including additional grants to
the state for mental health counseling
federal agencies have their crisis lines
opened up for people that just need to
talk to somebody and that's being
communicated but my advice to people is
you know you're coming off the
adrenaline of this you're now starting
to set in how bad it is and it seems
like this will never end it's never
going to get better you don't even know
where to start and I tell people one day
at a time these are going to be very
difficult long recovery periods and it
seems insurmountable and you got to work
this step by step but I just tell people
you need to take care of yourself one
day at a time Craig Fugate former FEMA
administrator current chief resiliency
officer for one concern thanks so much
for joining us thanks for having me
[Music]
and in other news I'm Gianna jalosi
plans are in motion to put the new king
of England on the Kingdom's currency
both in Great Britain and Beyond the
debate over which iconic faces should
appear on Australian currency has flared
up again two separate petitions are now
circulating online to feature crocodile
hunter Steve Irwin on the country's five
dollar bill instead of King Charles III
Queen Elizabeth II is featured on the
bill and on a coin assistant treasury
Minister Andrew Lee said the new king
may not replace his mom on the five
dollar note in the way the new coins
will feature him Lee saying the coin is
a matter of tradition but the Queen's
appearance on the bill was more about
Queen Elizabeth II's personality rather
than her role as a monarch a petition on
the parliament of Australia's website
argues no one is more vital to
Australian culture than Steve Irwin and
that the late zookeeper is beloved by
all and has become synonymous with
Australian values and quote more
importantly he's just a good bloke Irwin
died in September of 2006 after being
pierced in the chest by a stingray Barb
in the Great Barrier Reef six years ago
a fan tried to no avail to petition to
Adam to the 100 note the Royal Mint
that's the maker of British coins will
be phasing in the new King on British
money Australian Canadian and Belizean
dollars also all feature the queen and a
reminder of the British Empire's
Colonial reach for the Fox News rundown
I'm Gian jalozzi
personal powerful is America's weather
team in the palm of your hands get Fox
weather updates throughout your busy day
every day subscribe and listen now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your podcasts Raiden review the Fox News
rundown on Apple podcasts or wherever
you listen it's time for your Fox News
commentary Tammy Bruce what's on your
mind we've been watching the
radicalization of parents in our great
country as they stand up for their own
rights at school boards and in defense
of their children as covet remote
learning revealed the extent of leftist
indoctrination in schools one might be
under the impression that this is
exclusively a problem in the United
States but nothing could be further from
the truth attempts to indoctrinate our
children is an international problem
because it's part of the leftist agenda
wherever leftists hold sway in western
civilization using State agents to take
control of children and degrade the
concept of family remains an essential
objective now we have parents in the
United Kingdom striking back with some
success this is great news and we should
not be surprised no matter where you
live what language you speak what your
race or ethnicity no one lays around at
night dreaming about agents of the state
taking control of their children the
fact that leftist union members are
using the public education system and
children to further their agenda is
typical and has been developed over
decades for parents Nigel and Sally Rowe
in the United Kingdom the issue
surrounds transgender policy at their
boys school at least that's what leftist
activists want everyone to think
whatever the woke agenda issue in
schools it's really about manipulating
parents into believing their influence
with their own children is harmful and
limited it is about the left resting
control of children away from their
parents keeping parents shut out of the
education process and hacking away at
the very notion of family this is the
only point and children are the Pawns in
this sick game The Rose decided to take
action when their her six-year-old boy
came home from school confused about why
another boy was suddenly no longer a boy
and dressing as a girl they contacted
the school expressing their concerns and
were met with much more than just a cold
response the Christian Post reports in
July of 2017 the Church of England
officials wrote to the Rose explaining
the school doesn't require any form of
medical or psychological evaluation when
a student requests to be affirmed as a
member of the opposite sex the family
was given an ultimatum to accept the
policy or leave the school they and
their six-year-old Sons were told by a
church of England primary school that
they would be labeled transphobic if
they refused to accept policies that
require affirmation of two
trans-identified students gender
identities
and now an incredibly exciting
development after five years of fighting
the government finally settled and the
Rose won they paid the couple their
legal costs in the UK Department of
Education agreed to reform the
government's trans affirming policies in
schools for the rose as is the case for
parents here in the United States this
is not about transphobia it's about
parents rights Americans are fighting
back in a number of ways including
parents confronting school boards
running for office and lobbying their
state legislators many have shifted from
public schools to homeschooling or
private education parents becoming
mobilized in defense of their children
and of themselves as the moral cultural
and intellectual Arbiters of their
children is heartening and exciting it
bodes well for the future of our country
the UK and other nations facing the same
political agenda in schools leftist
activists intent on fundamentally
transforming this nation can only do so
with parents and family out of the way
so they bully and harass and try to
intimidate parents with name calling
threats and labels the left and
Democrats also want you to think that
fighting back is hopeless but they
continue to underestimate the American
people and especially American parents
but just like how the UK found out
courtesy of the Rose it doesn't take a
village it takes moms and dads
[Music]
podcasts.com and for up to the minute
news go to foxnews.com
foreign
[Music]
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as I take on American
Life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you download podcasts
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes